if you were trapped in a survival game
where you and 11 others could predict
when you'll die what would you do when
everyone can predict the future how do
you outsmart them to win the game I'm
here to break down the mistakes made
what you should do and how to be the
mobile death game in Future Diary this
kid's life is about to change forever
Yuki here is your typical
run-of-the-mill loser no one in his
school wants to talk to him and he
spends his days staring at his phone
with no social life whatsoever he spends
a lot of time writing in his diary on
his phone without any reason at all but
this small habit of his is going to
destroy the entire world at home he
closes his eyes and enters a whole new
dimension with the king of time and
space Deus his imaginary friend however
he's not alone Dave's helper murumuri is
there as well making fun of him for
always writing and his secret diary the
man is lonely but Deus gives him a way
to fix his life by playing a simple game
the next day Yuki wakes up and reads a
news report on his phone about a serial
killer who killed someone near his
school the phone texts him the rest of
his day with timestamps and intricate
details but the kid doesn't realize that
he's discovered something that will
change his life forever he gets up and
throws a dart which lands on a double
Bullseye exactly as it was written on
the text in school later he checks his
phone again to find out that all the
answers have been written down for him
to follow on his phone throughout the
day he watches as every single part of
the text that he receives begin to come
true right down to the smallest details
confused he goes back into the other
dimension and asks Deus what the hell is
going on and that's when this imaginary
space deity tells him the most insane
thing he tells him that he is a real God
and that Yuki now possesses something
called a Future Diary this device allows
you to see the future but if the diary
breaks if the phone breaks the owner
dies wow that is a lot to take in for a
heist school student if it were me
though I would be thinking about all the
possible opportunities presented to us
now that we can predict the future we've
just discovered a device that can solve
all of our problems fix world peace and
change my life forever now the first
thing I would do would be to get an
extremely adorable phone cover because
you never know when you might drop your
phone and instantly die and that would
suck however with great power comes
great responsibility and blah blah blahs
that saying goes we have a literal God
giving us this device to predict the
future but I have a strong feeling that
it's not going to be worth the hassle I
would kindly ask Deus to pick somebody
else to bless with this magical ability
while Yuki's life here might seem pretty
damn bad he's got no friends he's a
shut-in getting an infinitely powerful
device like this while still going
through puberty is not going to turn out
well so if I was him I'd avoid my
teenage angst and ask Deus to get rid of
my new powers ASAP the next day exams
are in session Yuki receives the answers
to all of his upcoming exams in his
phone diary and just as he's about to
pass the test with flying colors this
pink-haired girl you know glances at him
for a split second he doesn't realize it
but this girl knows exactly what's going
on when school is finished for the day
he gets a terrifying new text that says
at 6 pm on the dot somebody will follow
him home to kill him shocked the
pink-haired girl from before tells him
that this is his future he then runs out
of the school and sees on his phone that
the future is changing by the second
sprinting through the city he runs home
but this girl won't stop chasing him and
she opens the elevator door to kiss him
on the lips she mentions that she can
see the future as well and that she knew
that Yuki wouldn't retaliate with
violence as the elevator is going up
yuno points out that another serial
killer is lurking from the ground she
mentions that he's the third diary owner
and that she scared the killer away from
killing Yuki because her diary is
focused only on Yuki and she can predict
his future every 10 minutes she then
presses the button for the rooftop and
shows that if he were to have left on
the 14th floor he would have died and
she reveals that he's been entered into
a death game with other people just like
him yuno mentions that the killer near
them will find their location and says
that they'll do better out in the open
in order to escape before it's too late
Justin the killer enters from the
elevator doors and walks out onto the
rooftop only to find it empty ride as
Yuki hides nearby waiting for the
perfect time to strike then all of a
sudden yuno grabs the Killer's attention
from behind and Yuki hurls a dart right
into his phone destroying the phone and
killing the killer cold okay yeah that
was some crazy [__] and they should be
patting themselves on the back for that
smart play but Yuki here has a lot more
diary owners to face in the coming days
it's a lot of information to take in
Diaries weirdly dressed people trying to
kill us and knowing exactly what's going
to happen in the future there's a lot of
uncertainty going on which means we'll
need to be thinking two steps ahead at
all times if we want to beat this death
game and as Deus explained every single
contestant's Diary can potentially
predict what's going to happen 90 days
into the future now this weird
hyperbolic time chamber-like area that
we're in is probably going to be the
only chance we get to see our enemies
before they find us in the real world
I'm not entirely sure how phones would
work in this situation but since our
diary is our phone and we do have it
with us it might be useful to take some
photos of the other contestants if Deus
allows it assuming the other contestants
view us as Silhouettes just like we view
them it might be possible to do it
without anyone noticing from there we
could make up a fake story as to why we
need to identify these individuals at
the police station and go from there now
the important thing that most of these
contestants probably aren't considering
is the fact that this is a survival game
this means that all we have to do is
survive and we win the game being a
teenager we have the upper hand in this
situation because we're probably one of
the youngest here which gives us a
number of advantages it seems like yuno
here is willing to do anything to win us
over and I mean anything well that's
definitely not what you would want in a
normal healthy relationship it is great
for us right here all we have to do is
Pretend We're hot as hell for her and
she will do whatever she can to save us
if possible I would take her someplace
far away where none of the other
contestants could possibly find us even
with their Diaries once enough time has
passed and I've guesstimated that the
rest of the contestants are dead I'd
kill her with my charm and maybe a knife
and win the game chatting with Deus Yuki
gets angry at him for not telling the
truth about the other contestants and he
is transported to another room where the
Silhouettes of other diary holders
congratulate him on having the first
kill Deus then explains that the entries
and their Diaries stretch up to 90 days
into the future and adds that the future
can change depending on whether or not
the contestant follows what the diary
has set out for them meaning the future
truly is malleable Deus gives them a
final piece of information a
contestant's future will change when one
of them wants to kill the other this is
called a death entry a contestant who
receives this change in the future is
given a dead end call and must do
everything he or she can do to avoid it
Deus announces to everyone that the
winner will be given his throne and
become a God if they can survive but
since Yuki here was the first to get a
kill everyone now has set their sights
on him as their first Target that sucks
later after class Yuki approaches yuno
to learn more about the game and that's
when this purple hair girl pops in and
says that the serial killer that they
just killed is actually dead right as
she peeks at Yuki's cell phone and
realizes that he's the first suddenly
yuno rushes in and attacks this chick
before she reveals herself as the ninth
contestant blowing up the entire School
in an instant they survived the bombing
and Yuki here promises to kill the ninth
outside the purple hair girl announces
to the whole school that bomb sensors
have been placed all around the building
just as Yuki reads that there's
explosions on the stairs since he has
the random diary he's not allowed to
influence what future predictions are
given to him just then he sees that
class 2C is about to explode right
before Yuki comes in swinging saving his
ass in the nick of time well I think
anyone could have seen that coming a
mile away no normal person dresses in a
corset while going to high school
whether they had an anime convention not
to mention the previous diary owner we
just killed had a pretty eccentric
fashion sense as well so from now on I
would think it's safe to assume that
anyone we see dressing up as weird
looking characters we should then get
ourselves ready for some action now even
though the situation looks pretty dang
bad we're extremely lucky to have
avoided multiple explosions that could
have easily killed us looking on the
bright side of things folks it's two
against one and this girl you know is
ready to do damn near anything to keep
us safe that's a valuable thing to keep
in mind when trying to survive a red hot
situation using the diary we know that
going down any of the stairs is going to
cause another explosion leading to our
deaths this means that we really need to
really think outside of the box to
escape the night one option that we
would have would be to scale the wall on
the other side of the building which she
can't see us from however that's a lot
easier said than done and you need to
have the grip strength of a rock climber
and the balls to make it down without
falling to your death now it might sound
cold-blooded but there could be a way of
getting out that might sound simpler
than expected the knife purposely
announced on loudspeaker that the bombs
are activated by sensors this means that
hundreds of students currently stuck in
the building are at risk of getting
blown to shreds as well if they make any
wrong moves however when enough time
passes someone's going to take a chance
and that's our key to escape our random
diary is going to tell us exactly where
the bomb blasts are happening and
luckily for us all we have to do is stay
put in a classroom that's already been
blown up and waited out whether it takes
minutes or hours eventually the teachers
students someone will will lose their
cool and try running down the stairs
they'll explode and they'll die sucks to
be them but it will also create a safe
pathway for us to leave the building and
deal with the knife either outside or in
the near future right before they make
their way through the building while
avoiding the explosions using his diary
however Yuki's diary isn't focused on
what happens to himself so he can't
figure out what's going to happen in the
future suddenly Yuki gets a text that
he's about to be severely wounded just
as they survive the chaos from within
walking through the hallways everything
seems to be going fine but that's when
Yuki sees his classmate and runs over to
greet him they push him down after
hearing that the knife told them to
capture Yuki asking them to take his
cell phone in exchange for being set
free the students bring him downstairs
and the ninth gets ready to kill him but
that's when yuno runs out of the
classroom to save him detonating the
bombs from within the building she
announces that the rest of the bombs
will go off in 10 minutes killing
everyone in the surrounding area but her
plans are cut short when a mysterious
man interrupts the standoff and
introduces himself as the fourth
contestant and tells Yuki that he's not
the one being targeted but the ninth is
actually after the fourth this cop guy
this guy has the investigation diary
meaning he can see crimes happening in
the future he tells Yuki that he's not
interested in becoming God and only
wants to solve crimes to help people
however the ninth is done she threatens
to bomb the entire surrounding area
which causes the detective to change his
mind and points his gun towards Yuki but
suddenly yuno jumps from the building
window and tries attacking the ninth the
detective tells him to get his diary and
he runs through the landmines with
yuno's help grabbing the diary and
pissing off the ninth she rushes towards
yuno and throws her over getting ready
to detonate the bombs and take everyone
out but she's suddenly interrupted by
the other students who throw books and
everything that they have on them down
on her to distract her while she looks
away Yuna runs towards her and stabs her
right in the eye with no other option
she creates a small clout and drives a
motorcycle Michael out of the school
before revealing that she's the owner of
the Escape diary meaning she can escape
any sticky situation with ease forcing
the fourth AKA this detective guy to
invite the two to form an alliance with
him in order to hunt down the remaining
contestants okay after this incident
we're now all well and truly settled
into the insanity of this Survival game
our school's just been destroyed a girl
just literally whipped a motorcycle out
of her ass and there's a police officer
trying to negotiate with a teenage boy I
think it's time we take a breather from
all of this Ridiculousness now the first
thing I would do is to realize that
going to school is not a good idea
schools are an easy place to get tracks
and you're going to get hundreds of
innocent people killed if you care about
that in fact the entire city is probably
not a good place to be living in right
now while Deus could have picked anyone
to become a diary owner and take his
place as God it seems like he only
picked Japanese people while living in
sakurami city as rightful candidates if
it were me I would get the next train
out of Dodge and leave as soon as
possible it doesn't matter where I'm
going it just needs to be out of the
city now if we had some kind of money or
access to funds it would probably be a
good idea to leave the entire country
however I doubt that Yuki here has the
finances to do so so just to be safe I
would use Uno as protection and player
like a fiddle as in pretend to fake my
love for her as hard as possible because
she's extremely gullible but she's also
an incredibly terrifying knife-wielding
badass so we kind of have to dance on
the knife edge here a little bit since
we'll be called occasionally to meet up
with the other diary owners I should be
able to find out exactly when there's no
one left and kill you know myself in
order to win the survival game and
frankly you know would probably let me
kill her anyways the fourth explains
that they need to identify the remaining
7 out of 12 contestants but that their
main target is the ninth later that
night they walk back home before yuno
invites him to come over inside Yuki
goes to take a leak and walks through
the dark hallways to reach the bathroom
he then notices a strange room with duct
tape all over and decides to take a look
and find something that he'll never
forget dead bodies everywhere sprawled
out around the room leaving the boy
Frozen in shock just as you know shows
up out of nowhere and questions what
he's up to Yuki then runs away and locks
himself in his house as yuno's head
slips through to wish him a creepy good
night but the horrors aren't over for
him oh no no no as Yuki wonders just
what the hell he saw and even thinks
about calling the police just as yuno
hits him up and tells him to chill out
on that thought proving to Yuki that
escaping this hell hole is impossible
and that the worst for this death game
is Yet to Come the next day fourth picks
up Yuki at his house along with Creep
Show you know and he tells them that the
knife has been captured by a religious
group arriving at the temple this lady
introduces herself as the Priestess and
explains that her eyesight is limited
forcing her to have to reside indoors
for most of her life and she reveals
that she's the sixth contestant but she
tells them that she has no interest in
becoming God and isn't a threat she then
shows them her diary which reveals that
she's going to die tonight holding the
ninth underground she offers them a
trade hand over the ninth in exchange
for Yuki later on the sixth and Yuki
have a private conversation telling him
to not trust yuno however yuno's diary
is detailing everything she sang and
suddenly the wooden cage catches on fire
and her disciples begin murdering each
other in Cold Blood you know tells him
to not save the sex since the diary says
he'll die in the process but Yuki says
that he doesn't trust her because of the
night before and runs to the cage to
save the Priestess that's when suddenly
the sprinklers activate and the sixth
commands everyone to stop killing each
other she tells Yuki that someone must
be controlling her disciples she then
tries to check the location of the Enemy
by checking her diary and finds that
someone suspicious is staying in the
lodge and they find more and more
suspicious person reports around the
area before they realize that the
disciples have been hypnotized again
causing the diary to show inaccurate
reports they decide to walk outside as
you know here gets jealous with Green
Envy of Yuki and the priestess's new
friendship however they don't have time
to argue because their diary suddenly
changes showing Yuki has a dead end flag
horrified they have no idea where the
threat is coming from but that's when
yuno slashes the head of a dead corpse
suddenly the corpses rise from the dead
and begin attacking them just then you
know gives Yuki the option of staying
with her and living or trusting the
sixth and dying she's the only one
targeted by the disciples so all they
have to do is leave and they'll be free
of any danger you know pulls them a way
to get out but Yuki brings the Priestess
along meanwhile fourth here calls Yuki
to inform him that he'll continue
investigating the whereabouts of the
night and he's just called back up to
help them get out of the temple they run
as fast as possible but the girls get
into a disagreement which stops their
progress the detective then calls up
Yuki again and tells him to watch out as
the 12th is headed his way he then
informs him that the contestant is blind
but has amazing hearing skills just then
they suddenly spot a group of twelves on
a nearby roof one of them is the real
12th but they don't know who the group
of twelves jumps down and gets ready to
attack but they stop to mention that
their only target is the Priestess the
sixth is tricking them and she's more of
a cult leader than she is a priestess
and tells them that out of the five
twelves one of them has swallowed a time
bomb which will soon detonate Yuki then
reveals that a dead-end flag has been
set for him but he's willing to do
whatever it takes to kill the Priestess
okay Yuki here just missed a very big
chance to take out two contestants in
one go this is this is going to put him
in a world of trouble real soon okay now
while you know might seem like a crazy
you know the word at the moment it seems
like she definitely has our best
interest in mind this doesn't seem like
that complex of of an issue folks there
are no friends in this game so unless
you're crazy like you know then no
contestants should be making alliances
with each other neither the 12th or the
6th are on our side and the sixth is
nearly blind which means there's likely
no way she'll survive the game unless
she uses her disciples to her Advantage
however it seems like they're not the
most reliable people considering recent
events if it were me though I would
count my blessings and escape with yuno
the six will be attacked by her
hypnotized disciples or be killed by the
twelve due to her compromised ability to
see now if that happens the disciples
will most likely try their best to take
out the 12th meaning we've just killed
two birds with one stone you're welcome
the masked men rushed them so yuno here
throws a rock on the railing nearby
causing only one of them to look idiot
she notices the distracted enemy and she
strikes the tactic works out and the
12th contestant is brutally killed ah
dope suddenly an explosion goes off and
Yuki here collapses the Priestess
reveals that this was her plan all along
and these two are going to be killed by
her disciples who holds the kids up and
she gives Yuki a kiss goodbye but 6
checks her diary one last time and is
shocked beyond belief to see that she
now has a dead end flag enraged yuno
slashes the guards and runs straight
towards the Priestess slicing off her
hand she pushes Yuki off of the railing
before losing Consciousness however he's
now forced to run off because of the
disciples Yuki hides under the house and
hears the Priestess announced that
yuno's about to be badly wounded in one
of the worst ways imaginable if he
doesn't reveal himself he decides to
take the risk and runs into the open
room where yuno's being held scaring
them off with an ax the Priestess tells
him though that there's no hope but Yuki
here realized something his dead end
flag was never triggered which means he
still has options which means he still
has a chance he throws a ball into the
air to distract the disciples giving him
the opportunity to throw a dart straight
into her diary and killing the sixth the
next day Yuki picks up his mum from the
airport and they arrive at home to find
the front window broken he checks his
diary and realizes exactly what's going
on upstairs he finds Yuki cleaning his
room and tries his best to avoid his mom
entering his room she forces the door
open to find him and you know staring at
a dirty magazine that night they have
dinner and she introduces herself as
Yuki's girlfriend and she's taking off
all the boxes and Yuki's mother is an
absolute support of their relationship
and good thing too because Yuna would
have been more than willing to kill mom
if she didn't approve Yuki's mother lets
yuno sleep in the house overnight but
they're about to wake up to an
unexpected surprise Yuki's mom then
introduces them to this adorable child
race okay who'll be staying for the rest
of the day but he begins acting strange
nearly stabbing Yuki here with a pair of
scissors the mom tells him to put it
down so he goes off to the bathroom and
whips up a card that has yuno's name on
it his diary is the hypervision diary a
picture diary that only shows three
entries a day morning afternoon and
night the three of them have dinner
while the mom takes a call however this
cheeky kid has a special surprise for
the others he's poisoned the vegetables
but Yuki notices the vegetables are
heavier than usual so she decides to put
them away and that's when Yuki's diary
rewrites itself for a reason that they
haven't yet realized later the kid
begins tampering with the bathtub
planning to electrocute them when they
take a bath suddenly you can notices
that his diary has changed again meaning
another Diary owner must be nearby
shocked the text changes to read that
you know has been electrocuted he has no
time to run to the bathroom so he puts
his hair dryer on turbo and blows out
the power to the house he runs upstairs
to find her safe but they begin to
realize that this kid is more than meets
the eye okay that was terrifying this
kid has no regard for anyone's safety
rude and is ready to do the most Savage
things to kill and eliminate us from the
game we know that this kid possesses the
intelligence level of an adult and
that's extremely dangerous now at this
point there's no no doubt that this kid
is the diary owner while it might sound
like a terrible thing to do to a child
what they should have done is grab the
kid and smash his skull in on the
bathtub and teach him a lesson however
this kid is a kid after all and I don't
think Yuki's mom would be too happy
about it that we just killed the kid
she's been babysitting and the kid is a
crafty one but this is Yuki's house and
he knows the place inside and out he
should be using his surroundings to his
advantage to take the kid out without
him or you know being blamed accidents
happen all the time folks don't they
what we can do is kill the kid in our
sleep along with our mom now hear me out
you might be wondering why we have to
kill our mother alongside the kid and
here's why if we win this game we become
God this means that whatever actions
we've taken during the game should be
able to be reversed desperate times call
for desperate measures and Yuki here
should do whatever it takes to eliminate
another contestant after the kid falls
asleep Yuki suggests that they just
killed the Kid In Cold Blood however you
know here suggests they break his diary
instead dead that's when he walks out
and tells them they have no chance of
finding it checking around the house
yuno's diary shows no signs of other
Diaries and she decides to dig around
the house with Yuki but when he turns
around she disappears yuno decides to
take matters into her own hands and
chases the kid around the house with a
hammer with a swing and a miss she
accidentally hits Yuki's mom and knocks
her out they realize that their current
methods aren't going to work so yuno
decides to put herself in the mind of a
child and she realizes that the kid has
ordered a package delivery and that the
diary is hidden inside of it suddenly
Yuki's diary changes and says that the
package is about to release poison gas
he opens it and passes out but the kid
creepily here has a gas mask handy and
he reveals that the poison wouldn't have
activated if he opened the package from
the other side and now they're both
screwed they hide in the toilet away
from the gas while the kid proposes they
play a game of hide and seek if they win
he'll hand over the antidote yuno goes
at it alone covering her mouth while
running outside and she searches every
single nook and cranny of the house but
can't manage to find out where the kid
went finally she sees him while running
up on the second floor however this kid
doesn't want to play by the rules she
notices water flowing down the stairs
and that's when the kid throws a light
bulb down electrocuting yuno just as
he's about to finish the job Yuki fires
the dart of the kid and he runs off yuno
recovers and walks upstairs finding the
kid completely defenseless without Mercy
she brutally stabbed the kid through the
chair two weeks later Yuki joins a new
school but is greeted by a familiar face
this bully kosaka and he starts to try
and tell everyone what Yuki did when
their previous school got blown to
Smithereens however this busty looking
girl Hinata hits the bully and tells him
to stop causing problems and her polite
friend Mal walks in and they introduce
themselves to Yuki after school the four
of them meet up with yuno and they
decide to take a look at a nearby crime
scene they find chalk marks on the way
way and realize that they're in the
right direction and they find themselves
on top of the city and Hinata here goes
ahead without them and she finds herself
caught in a forested area completely
alone and that's when something sinister
strikes Yuki and yuno realize that their
Diaries have changed which can only mean
one thing there's another contestant
nearby he checks his diary to see a text
saying Hinata's corpse is on the hill
ahead and they run towards the forested
area and find a dismembered arm beyond
that is Hinata's dead body suddenly with
an insane amount of creepy coincidence
this white-haired kid akuse shows up out
of nowhere to lend them a hand while
vicious dogs walk out of the forest and
Chase the group as they run as fast as
they can to a nearby Observatory okay
these definitely aren't your
run-of-the-mill dogs they're huge hineda
here is dead meat and we should let that
go and move on because we're going to be
next if we don't do something fast
however while it might have worked out
for some reason running away from a
group of rabid dogs is the worst thing
that you can do in a situation Nation
like this Japan isn't a country known
for being overrun with feral dogs like
these bad boys but it does have a large
population of dogs with the Japanese
owners owning over 8.5 million dogs with
this many of them some of them are bound
to end up escaping and becoming feral
now the first thing you should do is not
panic hard to do I know but dogs are
capable of smelling fear which may or
may not make them want to approach us
even more either way it's better to keep
your cool and make yourself look as big
and intimidating as possible if this
doesn't work and the dogs keep
approaching us it might be better to
think up some other options most dogs
are capable of outrunning humans and
this means it's a bad idea again to run
we need to look around our environment
for things that we can use to keep us
safe the only thing in our general
vicinity are trees so that should be our
next best bet our group consists of five
people including ourselves which means
that we can use the other four as bait
some of the group has the physical
ability to climb up the trees I'm sure
but there's bound to be a few that can't
manage it all that well and will be
forced to run this would grab the
attention of the dogs and leave us with
a window of opportunity to run in the
opposite direction back into town making
it safely inside the kid introduces
himself as a world famous detective but
yuno interrupts to say that the dogs
might be controlled by one of the people
here suddenly the dogs begin to make
their way inside Yuki reads his diary
which confirms that he doesn't have long
before the canines rips them all to
shreds using his diary He commands
everyone to hold alternating windows
down so the dogs can't break through
after hours of holding down the fort the
dogs finally run off and leave the kids
alone kosuka complements him on his
strategic prowess and Yuki admits that
his cell phone told him exactly what to
do hearing this Mao comes from behind
and holds a knife to his neck she takes
his cell phone and that's when hineda
walks in she reveals herself also as a
diary owner however Yuki isn't her
Target I is she explains that she left a
dead body as a decoy and Yuki here was
bait to get akise out of hiding akise
tells her that he'll hand over the phone
but first he has to guess which hand the
coin is in but with Yuki's diary she
knows exactly what's going to happen so
she picks the right hand just as it says
on the screen Yuki motions towards yuno
in order to let her know what hand she's
going to play but Hinata here knows
exactly what's going on and changes the
coin to her left hand however akise
picks the left hand and ends up winning
the game and Hinata checks the diary to
see even more entries pop up and he
proposes that they start the game for
real now it's akise's turn she bets on
the right hand but she's wrong and the
girls are forced to let Yuki free
suddenly Yuna pushes wide-haired akise
to the floor and forces him to admit
whether or not he's a diary owner and he
tells them that it was just pure luck
that he won and suggests that they
resume the game to get Yuki's diary back
and they agree for one final game if
akise wins he gets the diary if Hinata
wins they get fed to the dogs she puts
the coin in her right hand and yuno
covers Yuki's ear akise here guesses the
right hand but pretends that he got it
wrong to Yuki now his diary changes
based on his internal belief meaning
Hinata here can't use it as a method to
win however it's not a foolproof plan
Aki say here has a 50-50 chance to win
the game and he managed to win suddenly
Yuki Sprints towards hineda with deadly
intentions but malhir jumps in front of
her and takes a knife to her body the
rest of them then decide to leave the
observatory but hineda here isn't
satisfied she calls the dogs to chase
them down but akisahir suggests that
they split up the three of them distract
the dogs while Yuki tries to save hineda
the two boys leave but yuno decides to
head back to the observatory as well
when they arrive yuno Sprints over to
hineda and threatens to Slit her throat
if she doesn't call off the dogs Yuki
tells yuno not to kill her just destroy
her diary instead she tells Yuki that
she's scared of of Canada and Yuki's
relationship thinking that they might be
dating but Yuki says hell to the No-No
and calls you know his girlfriend which
thank God calms her down surprised he
ended up thanks him for his forgiveness
some time later Yuki carries yuno back
to her house inside he finds akise
waiting for them he then realizes that
the room with the dead bodies has been
opened and freaks out however they walk
inside to find it completely empty and a
massive hole has been dug out the boys
walk home together and akuse theorizes
that yuno has completely forgotten about
the dead body incident because of her
fragile mental state meanwhile at the
police station the detective informs the
officers about Hinata's father's death
he tells them that he's found two
potential suspects Yuki and yuno
thinking about what akise said Yuki here
begins to realize that he's the only
thing keeping you know from going
absolutely insane and that's terrifying
that's when he's approached by nishijima
and the police who asked him to come to
the station him and yuno end up at the
station waiting to be interrogated and
Yuki hears called to go first and meets
up again with the detective fourth the
man asks him if he wants to play a game
of Russian Roulette and informs him that
they no longer have an alliance together
the detective wants to become God and
there's nothing he can do about it
suddenly yuno forces herself in and
shoots the detective multiple times
killing him they then take the
detective's assistant hostage and run
off however they don't realize that
they've made a huge mistake because the
detective was wearing a bulletproof vest
since he holds an investigation diary
this means he can predict the future
when a legal case appears which is
exactly what's happening right now they
run to the fire exit while being chased
by the guards inside one of the officers
threatens to shoot them Yuki hear fears
for his life and reacts by shooting the
officer in the stomach he's just killed
someone in Cold Blood for the first time
and there's no going back from there
they then run all the way to the roof
and blah kiss each other before jumping
off onto the roof of a truck how
romantic okay now I will admit that was
a ballsy move and had an extremely good
chance of going terribly wrong and it
should have judging by the size of the
building it looks to be over 10 or so
stories tall while it might not sound
like much doctors estimate that a
seven-story drop AKA 48 feet will lead
to a 90 chance of people dying terribly
painful deaths now it might have worked
out in the end but there are a few other
options they could have taken that
wouldn't have risked them of being
paralyzed for the rest of their lives or
dead looking at the assistant we can
clearly see that the man was not going
to shoot them this gives us a little bit
of time to think about the situation at
hand and consider the negatives of
jumping off of this roof potentially we
could have pretended to surrender
ourselves to the police and taken the
assistant as our hostage with this we
could have grabbed his gun and kept it
for ourselves to make sure we have some
kind of offense to deal with the
incoming officers it's only a matter of
minutes ago that detective forth was
trying to play a game of Russian
roulette with a teenage boy I don't know
about you but that's pretty darn messed
up if we can convince everyone to stop
shooting each other then we might be
able to suggest that we can check the
surveillance footage in the
interrogation room to prove that we're
just some innocent teenager and that the
fourth is the real bad guy here because
he's the one pointing a gun at us a
teenager sounds pretty convincing to me
the next day the couple AKA turned
fugitives are now hiding away from any
police or civilians and their Diaries
predict dead ends if they leave for food
so they're stuck inside this freaking
tiny shed with nowhere to go absolutely
starving they smell donuts and take a
look outside to find this smart looking
lady heading to the hospital they follow
her inside when suddenly a bomb goes off
and the knife restrains Yuki and he
accidentally presses a button that
causes another bomb to go off leaving
the two stuck Yuna goes to find a ladder
and puts it down for Yuki to cross but
the ninth demands that she go first and
she proposes that they form an alliance
for now and it may immediately gets a
dead end on her phone the message states
that the detective will kill her but she
ignores it she promises to tell them why
the detective portrayed them and opens
up the hospital door to find the smart
lady from before she's the detective's
wife and this is his son he's terminally
ill and the fourth wants to become God
in order to save him which makes
everything that the fourth just did
totally morally okay and in the right
realizing that all three of them have
dead ends in their Diaries they tie his
wife up to use her as a bargaining
tactic fourth tells Yuki to scout the
area while Yuna watches the hostages she
gives him a grenade and the kid heads
off ninth calls the detective and tries
to negotiate a deal but he doesn't care
armed forces have surrounded the
building and he's not backing down he
decides to take matters into his own
hands and tells his assistant to go find
the hostages yuno tells Yuki to run but
it's too late the soldiers take him down
and restrain him suddenly the detective
and yuno Sprint towards each other with
vicious intent taking out all the
soldiers in the process the detective
grabs Yuki and points a gun to his head
but you know here threatens to detonate
a grenade if he doesn't let go meanwhile
the ninth sets a timer for a bomb in
five minutes the entire building will be
blown to shreds and she uses the bed
sheets to repel down to the ground floor
but runs into the detective's assistant
on the way the detective decides to let
Yuki go and tells yuno to put the
grenade down suddenly she pulls the pen
on the grenade and grabs the detective
by the neck however it turns out to be a
flash grenade leaving the three of them
incapacitated noticing this from below
ninth and the detective's assistant run
to their location Yuki wakes up in a
pile of rubble and the detective grabs
Yuna with a knife to her neck Yuki finds
a gun but checks his diary and sees that
shooting the detective isn't going to
work out with no other option he takes
the chance anyway and the bullet lands
right into the fourth's stomach now he's
pissed and he tries to slice yuno but
his assistant and the ninth interrupt
the action and calm him down ninth whips
out her phone and shows evidence of the
detective promising to give her police
information to keep her safe hearing
this the detective's assistant formally
places the fourth under arrest and they
tell him that his wife and kids are safe
so the detective decides to spare them
the trouble and breaks his phone
eliminating him from the game and
disappears Into Thin Air after the
incident Yuki and yuno's names are
cleared and they no longer have to worry
about the police luckily for Yuki that
cop was pretty damn strong and survived
the gunshot the couple then decides to
go on a day trip and waits for the train
to visit Yuki's dad that's when suddenly
Yuki here gets a text from akusei
telling him to stay away from yuno the
police are following her for unknown
reasons and that he should keep his
distance however you know here is the
one reading the text and she deletes the
message before he comes back and they
then board the train and if you don't
want no diary dealing God to make you
get off your ass and fight then like
comment let us know what you liked and
of course didn't like and don't forget
to check out the how to be playlist down
below